All right folks welcome back this is episode 18 of the continuing series of the ICT 2022
YouTube mentorship.
All right so we are looking at the euro dollar and what you have here is how I have my trade
layout this is what I work with while utilizing my charts through trading view and don't be
intimidated because you may not be able to do this with your trading view there's a I
think there's a membership level you have to have and again I'm not trying to promote
I don't get anything for you signing up with trading view I don't have any affiliate programs
nothing like that I don't have any you know programs that I'm trying to pitch I just like
the service okay I pay for it out of my pocket you don't have to do me any favors so but
I have it set up like this when I'm looking at the marketplace the upper left hand corner
now you can do this with individual charts and you'll see what I mean by having one laptop
one screen if you do what I'm going to show you here today you don't need all these screens
but I've been asked to show this both in my private group and in the YouTube community
what do my charts look like when I'm going through the motions of looking for trade setups
and how do I navigate from higher time frame down to the lower time frame and how I work
with daily bias and what do I do with my charts to streamline the analysis from high time
frame to low time frame I'm going to show you that in this lesson here all right so
upper left hand corner is always going to be the daily chart you can see here daily
now if you're looking for bias you're going to start your analysis here now you can do
it with the chart maximize like this start working with it doing all of the business
that you would expect to have on your chart and we'll do this here shout out to my mentorship
private group I mentioned this on Wednesday's midweek commentary a little bit of hindsight
done right so we have a fair value gap there and notice that it has this high that low
and a higher high many of you would see that as my bearish breaker it's not okay so look
at this here which is lower is it this low here or the discount low of the fair value
gap in the words this candles high clearly it's this candles high so I'm going to tell you
something I told my private group last night because I can tell it to you now it's not
advantageous to you it was advantageous for them because they knew about it yesterday but
I'm showing you this because I have a lot of witnesses that I said this before it happened
because I know some of you out here unless you were there watching it okay you just simply won't
believe it and that's fine I'm not here to convince every single one of you you're gonna
believe it or you're gonna watch somebody else's channel symbols that but the fair value gap in
here I mentioned that we would likely draw up into that and then look for lower prices now let's
step-by-step walk through a scenario using what I'm teaching you in this mentorship on the YouTube
channel okay I responded to a lady on the comment section of I think it was the most recent video
so forgive me if it isn't that video but I know I mentioned a response to her question was more
or less I'm gonna paraphrase it can I touch on or teach a specific approach to trading or can I
mention rather a specific style of trading that if I only had to pick one way of doing it one style
of trading that obviously hits all the time well there is no method that hits every single time
everything that I trade with and teach is like everything else it's imperfect that means there's
gonna be losing transactions largely because of the operator me or whoever else is using it and
you have to take ownership of that it takes a great deal of responsibility and I kind of
lectured on that in my private group on Wednesday it doesn't feel good to hear those types of wood
shed lectures but it's something I needed when I was younger but if I was going to use one
particular approach to trading like say I was starting completely over didn't know anything
but I discovered like say this YouTube channel knowing what I know about all the things that
I can utilize in trading the reason why I stripped it all down and created the model like it is
and you're gonna see more of it being applied here today so it gives you like a step-by-step
approach and there's some of you over asking can you just kind of like show me what it is I'm trying
to do in a charts like what am I looking for what's what's a way of back testing you know how can I
go through look at old data I'm gonna show you something here but it was also given to my
community yesterday okay and if I see a bunch of comments in the comment section saying that it
wasn't really done I'll just simply upload the video and prove everybody that says that wrong so
I'm ready I'm ready for it so the long short is it's not a big deal it's not a huge trade
but it's proving prognostication it's proving that number one I've already hinted that this
thing was likely to go lower anyway and we've seen it go lower but utilizing the model this
model here in the YouTube 2022 mentorship that to me is the easiest and I would just do this I
wouldn't worry about doing anything with like central bank dealers range okay I wouldn't worry
about doing anything with Asian range I wouldn't even worry about doing anything with the well
there's a anything else unless I've mentioned it in this model I wouldn't even do any investment
of time at all because this literally is the simplest way to work with intraday and daily
order flow it's simple it really is this simple it doesn't feel sexy though I know some of you
young guys are like yeah but wait till he starts bringing out all the really hard-hitting you know
gadgets and such you're gonna be floored by that no you don't need it I don't want my daughter
inundated with all that stuff number one she's really not interested in trading so I'm trying
to convince her that she could do this with something it's very simple it's streamlined so
what does that mean by streamlining it and what is the step-by-step process because I already told
you the bias I've had on this currency when I taught one Tuesday I gave you a forex lesson I
showed you an example with the euro I said it's likely to draw into this low here now here's
the wonderful thing we don't even need it to go down to that low to find profitability how's
that how is that possible but how are you able to responsibly handle daily bias work with the
higher time frame and then frame out a setup using the logic that I'm showing you in this
model let's do that now number one the bias is bearish so if a bearish bias is being implemented
okay in order to using that in your analysis you're going through the charts looking for
setups that would warrant a short sale on this particular market or this pair in forex what
I'm showing you here all of this up to now if I make a transition to index futures trading I'll
mention certain caveats when it comes to that but for now everything I'm saying in this video
until I say otherwise is pertinent to forex okay so it's specific to forex alright so biases
bearish and we're looking at a daily chart so you start your analysis there you have a fair value
gap here so it can trade up into that and all you have to see is that candle traded to there
now you can be greedy and try to trade all the way up into the middle point or deep into it
maybe in complete closure I don't need that and we're gonna bring in the element of time of day
and how that helps you decide what you're looking for and you don't really need to catch that high
the day either so I'm gonna show you how to be forgiving with your entries the important thing
is knowing what you're looking for ahead of time so that way you're not changing gears back and
forth in your day chasing an impulsive price swing that may feel like oh I'm probably wrong
let me chase this let me chase that when I showed the three months live trading account statements
what some of you are not listening to when I say in the video listen to the videos okay when I'm
showing those statements I'm disclosing the fact that I'm getting questions by my students these
folks have paid me okay they asked for me to show them things in a live account you are not privy to
all of those conversations because you're not in that community so when they're asking me questions
like what do you do if you get this this and this and this how would you work with that in
in a real market I'm literally putting myself in a live account creating those very similar
situations that they're asking me about and then moving out of those periods of either drawdown
or how to overcome the anxious I don't want to take a trade I'm scared what happens if you take
losing trades how do you overcome that a lot of those executions you're seeing is just simply me
pushing a button to show that yes you can do those types of things to overcome initial fear it's
gonna cost you commission it's gonna look like you have no idea what you're doing and there's
people out there looking at these statements I've encouraged all of you to do it but it isn't gonna
mean anything to you unless you understand what I'm really illustrating here you're not the student
that was spoken to in private with that live account showing that actual event unfolding so
just know that there's a lot of things that are going on that are not necessarily your business
okay the community here wanted to see a live account you see in a live account but working
within a live account unless you do things like I'm gonna show you here you're gonna have this
changing of direction intraday over and back and forth back and forth you're gonna go up you're
gonna go down you're gonna go back and forth and then it's gonna draw your account down or worse
if you don't control yourself you'll blow the account so you have to commit to one direction
that's your bias here's the thing your bias isn't going to be perfect and here's a news flash for
you as well I'm not always perfect with my bias either a bias is just an idea that you want to
work within and employ your short sale when you're bearish or employ your long trade ideas when
you're bullish and you're filtering out the other side of the marketplace unless you're proven
clearly that you're absolutely wrong you just simply wait for these setups to form with that
bias in mind now I know a lot of you are new and you want to see things taught to you that simply
remove any chance of you losing there is no secret for that here nobody's gonna teach that
to you because it doesn't exist and frankly if someone had that I'll be real honest with you
folks if I had a way that I would never lose I would have never came out publicly and became
a teacher I would be the richest person you never met that's the God's honest truth that's exactly
what would happen and if there's somebody out there that has some kind of a means of never losing
they're doing that very thing you're never going to talk about it they're never going to teach it
so you don't need to be perfect and I've proven in perfection still doubles the account
it's simple and you can have a lot of losing trades and this is one of the things that one
of my students asked they said what if your win rate is really really low can you still
double an account yes because I was thumbing my nose at this idea that a risk to reward model
is essential for you to be net profitable that's not true I've proven that with a live account
I have lots of things I'm going to show you with this TD Ameritrade account before the end of the
year but just know that there are future lessons that I'm going to literally go through and show
you not everything obviously because you're not I'm not obligated to show you everything that the
other community is entitled to but I don't need to show you everything to see that account growing
now the question is is what do you do if you're in a live account let's let's paint a picture
for you okay say you're one of those individuals out there that have got caught up in the fever
of all these funded account programs okay I'm not going to name any in particular because I don't
have an affiliation with one I don't want an affiliation with any of them and I don't have
any personal experience with my own trading with any of them okay so that way we know I'm not
repping anyone there's no inside you know kick back for me none of that stuff but there's a
number of them out there and my opinion of them is I have students that have gone through them
and they are funded do I believe everyone should do that I don't personally believe everyone should
but it is an avenue that you have to consider it when you're in your own seat if you want to
do that or not but let's assume that you've gone through the process and now you have
passed whatever that you know I guess the challenge or whatever they call it to get funded
and you found yourself with a let's say a hundred thousand dollar account in other words you have
the ability to trade with what would be considered a hundred thousand dollars
what process if it were me doing that okay that's I'm going to speak in that perspective
now I'm not saying you should do this notice that what I'm saying here if it were me and I
was starting out all over again I would use this model and I would go through the process of what
I'm going to show you right now okay so there's uh daily bias and I'm going through the daily
chart and I'm looking at recent price action so we had this big drop down here drawing towards
this low and then the next day we had this candle trade up here so that creates the fair value gap
so ideally you know what we've seen here we had one two three four five down days
now there's likely to have a retracement because we've seen it come way down in terms of the range
between this low and this high so what does that make that area down here premium or discount
discount so as soon as this fair value gap forms we know that it's likely to see it
rally up into this area here in other words a short term little bounce
that occurring and trading back to this candle's high is enough to set the stage for a new round of
selling so you highlight your area on your daily chart and then look at what we have in terms of
targets this is an ideal scenario that low but it's not likely to do that in one day can it do it
absolutely but look at what is available in terms of targeting this day here it created the fair
value gap so that means we can go in and note that low right there and we'll change it to blue
here okay and we're going to put a little line segment here on this daily candle
and we'll mark that one red okay so we have more or less a premium level that's being highlighted
you can see it touches it but it actually goes above it just a little bit and that's all we'll
need to justify a framework okay now let me recap real quick bearish bias we're likely to draw down
to this low here why because we had one two three times like i mentioned on the video on tuesday
or episode 17 if i'm not mistaken in this mentorship so it's likely to draw lower
and dig into this low that's our draw on liquidity on the daily chart but is that your trade target
no not for intraday trading so you frame your daily highs and lows previous daily high previous
daily low so we have this day here you know yesterday's trading or what would be considered
wednesday's trading and then thursday's trading we opened here we rallied up popped just above
that short-term high and now because we've seen that we can target that daily low right here
okay so this is the trading day on thursday we open rally up created judas swing run back into
this fair value gap and then expect it to sell off and then we can aim for that daily low why
because anybody that went long in here who would want to do that there's always buyers and sellers
okay so we're going to use previous days highs and lows like institutional mindset traders do
there's lots of liquidity around daily highs and lows and high frequency trading algorithms
attack previous days highs and lows if you were back in the baby pitch days when i came on the
scene 2009 2010 that was the first lesson i started talking about is highlight the previous
day's highs and lows and do that for the last three days if you do that you'll see a plethora
of setups that you can do and that gives you liquidity pools that you can attack you there's
always a fresh supply of new setups if you're looking at the last three days highs and lows
it's always the case it's always going to be there you're never going to run out of trades ever okay
okay so we have our framework here we have the actually let me change this blue
to that green okay so we have premium and discount so these two levels are represented
on the high and low of wednesday's trading which would be yesterday straight in other words your
chart would have looked like this wednesday going into thursday before thursday started trading you'd
have this so you would mark your chart out like this so if we go up here and we enter this fair
value gap that's your opportunity to go in looking for shorts then if it starts to go down you're
targeting this low with the expectation why is it likely to do that because it may want to go down
to this low but this gives you a nice range of profitability potential profitability so a range
of we'll just call that 935 to a low of what is it what's the low here
74 so 25
six we'll call it 60 60 handles okay not bad that's a pretty respectable range
can you get 25 pips out of that can you get 30 pips out of that how about 40 pips what we're
going to find out but this is the range of opportunity that exists looking at wednesday's
trading and then thursday we open we rally up we bump that high like we would expect trading back
into that fair value gap and then we watch price does it give us a setup what setup would have
taught you in this mentorship so we're going to drop down into the lower time frame if you have
this layout like this so whatever you do in one chart it would appear in all the other time
frames which is really nice this is one of the things that i'd like to use in trading view not
that trading view is the only platform because obviously you can do this with everything out
there today but it's just really nice to be able to do this with all my students they can do the
same thing but if you're working with one screen like a laptop and i'll answer this while i'm
talking about it should you be trading on your phone no no you shouldn't can you manage a trade
on your phone yes but entering a brand new position on your phone no you don't see enough data
it's just too compressed and you need to be able to see the lay of the land okay you need to be
able to open your chart up and really take in the information if you don't do that folks you're
really just looking at a small little small little perspective really if you want to have
advantages you do it with a computer screen okay if you want to be handicapped then obviously try
to trade on your phone okay i have not met anyone that has been consistently profitable and trading
millions of dollars and they trade on their phone it just it doesn't work like that folks
you got to be responsible you have to have some real estate and yes it requires a little bit of
investment but hey you don't need all kinds of things you don't need all the screens like i have
and other people i have out there i'm showing you how you can do this one screen one monitor so what
would that look like obviously you can see everything i did on the daily chart is transposed
onto the hourly chart down here in the lower left hand corner and it's transposed over here
to the 15 minute time frame so the time frames are upper left is daily lower left is hourly
and 15 minute time frame is only right the 15 minute time frame is my bellwether chart that's
the one that i go to quickly i want to keep referencing that 15 minute time frame throughout
the day because the information i get from it which i'm going to show you is influential to
me in terms of managing my position or hunting or stalking a new trade setup
and also it helps me trust my intraday bias and i'll i'll explain that when we get into that
specific time frame but let me go back for a second to the daily because i want to bring
something up if you're using one screen okay you would obviously do this annotation here and then
in this screen you would just simply change it to the hourly chart and then everything you did here
would be transposed over to the trading view chart that would be on the hourly chart rather
and then once you've done whatever breakdown and markups that you would have for your hourly chart
then you would drop down to the 15 minute time frame and all of the annotations from the daily
and the hourly would appear on your 15 minute chart as you'll see okay so let's go back to
the layout and i'm going to maximize the hourly chart
all right so i like to do these types of things bring it to the actual level i'm
anchoring to because i have obsessive compulsive disorder so it is what it is it's a struggle
folks so in here it's this imbalance on the daily chart but now we can see it also exists
in the hourly as well so we have what this high and this high what are they
they're relative equal highs anchored to that point right there okay so usually
in my annotations i'm going into the chart
and this is for the purposes of showing you how to back test and how you annotate your chart
okay you toggle it to show on the top left and you can use whatever color you want
and there you go so we had the annotations that would be on your chart for
logging purposes for your study journal and then you would just screenshot this okay you might want
to zoom in a little bit you know make the chart a little bit more aesthetically pleasing
having something like that more you know more information zoomed in to a specific area
and then simply go in and start working with the 15 minute time frame because this is all i would do
with the hourly chart because the frame of reference is that daily fair value gap we have
liquidity pool on the hourly chart we've already mapped out the sixth of april's low notice there's
no lower low this low didn't go down to it and we start a new day on the seventh here at midnight
new york local time what do i mean by new york midnight i'm going to answer that let's go to
the 15 minute time frame here and as you can see we already have that little annotation updated on
the 15 minute time frame so now here's the 15 minute time frame and i apologize for all of you
that would otherwise know how to do this but obviously it's a mentorship right there's a lot
of people in the comment section that are asking for these types of lessons and once i go through
this this episode we won't ever have to revisit it again okay so bear with me okay all right so now
we have on the 15 minute time frame we're going to annotate the daily dividers this always is a
little vertical line okay and this little bar here is just my favorites bar and you can google that
for setting that up these are the things i use most in trading view so when i expand the chart
to maximize the full screen i highlight the little star button in the lower left hand corner just
below the little link button if you click that link button any chart you have open that's the same
symbol any all the annotations will be plotted and placed on all the time frames of that instrument
or that pair or that market so in other words if like i was showing you what my trading layout
upper left hand corner daily hourly lower left hand and 15 minute time frame on the right it's
the biggest chart hitting that little link button icon will again link all your charts together so
whatever you're showing the annotations on on one time frame will appear on all of them that's how
this is happening okay you can google that too and there's a lot of tips you can get off of
youtube for trading view most of my tips i actually got from my students which i appreciate
because they're more fluent with this i came from mt4 and trade station so
i'm a work in progress with trading view so so you're gonna drop a vertical line here
to dilini a new day at midnight what is the opening price at new york
midnight that's this candle and you highlight that and this price right here
that right there if you're looking at the time frame on the hourly
that would be the opening price i'm interested in that on a 15 minute time frame
or if i'm going to be scalping i'm going to use the five minute chart okay and i'll put two
reference points on the five minute chart but for the sake of this discussion just know that that's
the actual price i'm looking at and i'm drawing that out in time how far am i drawing it out
11 o'clock in the morning new york local time how do i know my chart's going to look like ict
right that's what you're asking you toggle it to new york i don't care where you live
i don't care where you're at in all the different time zones your trading view chart needs to be
set to this if you do that your chart will match all the things i'm teaching and the things i'm
teaching you to look for will be easier to find okay everything will be streamlined in terms of
time of day all right so now we have the bi-cell liquidity pool the daily denomination of midnight
new york time and we're going to take a little line segment here and we're going to plot it
right on here now i'm just going to just rough it because it's basically a little tiny indecisive
candle i don't care the difference between the actual open and close it's very minute
but i'm going to draw that on here and if you drag your your trend line over to the right if
you hold down the shift button it'll keep your trend line straight okay and just drop it there
and i'll just make this a gray color here now you can annotate that but over time doing it
you'll just know that that's what you're anchoring and showing this is the opening price at midnight
okay now we have the relative equal highs here we rallied above them once it hits this do we get
displacement now we get down to nitty gritty okay we have a swing low here it breaks down below
that and then once it does that does it create an imbalance is there a fair value gap
hint hint nudge nudge you see that all right so we're going to annotate that so inside of this
range here we have a fair value gap and i'm going to highlight this we'll just use this color here
now these are probably not the best colors you're probably cussing me right now saying why are you
using these ugly colors ict it's mainly just to annoy you so that way you can get more attentive
pay attention because this is a long video already so we're looking at the market wanting to go
higher first to go lower and here's that midnight delineation starting a new day
we rally up and then we break down so what's the model teach trading when
the new york session okay so we're trading the new york session in 4x it's seven o'clock in the
morning to ten o'clock in the morning right there okay so ten o'clock in the morning
and seven o'clock so we're looking for a setup that would be formed
within that time frame now you can create killzone windows annotations on your chart
there's lots of ways i've done this over the years you can do it whatever way you want to do it
inside center and we'll make it black and there you go so the new york killzone it runs up into
that runs the highs and we want to see a displacement to the downside we get right there
okay so now you have this area here and then you would put your order in right there and then you
would put your order in right there what time is that it's ten o'clock so you put your limit order
in to sell short rate at that price right there or plus one period and your risk is going to be
above this high the imbalance is really stretched out you can use that as your stop
if you're really concerned you can put your stop above the swing high but whenever you have a big
range like that my stop can place right there so your stop would be here and you're going to go
short here that's the minimum expectation using the 15 minute time frame but we're going to split
the 15 minute time frame down into five minute intervals okay so we're going to look inside
this range here and see if it's advantageous for us to go down into a five minute chart
and does it have a fair value gap in that all right so we're looking at the five minute chart
now and it's that shaded area here so it's using this specific candle or that low and we're looking
inside this range right here okay so it's this decline we're looking at does it have fair value
gap well we have this small one right in here see that we have this stretched out one here yes
and then we have all this run in here where it has a small little fair value gap so now think
about what's been shown on that 15 minute time frame we have a minimum threshold of at least
reaching into this low okay remember i showed you on the 15 minute time frame that imbalance
so it needs to get up into that okay so i'm answering the question that i saw or it really
wasn't a question it was someone trying to make a point that was i showing something incorrectly
by showing a higher time frame fair value gap because wouldn't the smaller time frame fair
value gap form before the higher time frame no it never works like that the higher time frame
imbalances are going to be parent to the subordinate smaller time frames okay the parent
okay is this 15 minute time frame imbalance so it needs to get above that but when it does that
it does that we have to look at the lower time frame below 15 minute time frame which is the
beginning stages of our fine-tuned entry of five four three two and one time frames
so here we have the five minute chart we have an imbalance right here and then we have that small
one right in here and all up to this price point here we could factor that in but it's not likely
to get up there so we can look at what this level here that is the minimum expectation
you can put a cell limit order there to go short or you can fine-tune this to rebalance all the way
up to here right there in other words it would look like this this would be your imbalance on
the five minute chart and if it traded up into that right there okay in other words you could use
any tank any specific price in this range here you can pick
this is where the unique style for you comes in if you get greedy you may not get your fill
so i'm teaching you the low threshold entry but that always will give you the highest
risk but that higher risk in terms of number of pips not in terms of the amount of money
because that part is always controlled by you the trader you can manage the amount of leverage
you're using and it doesn't matter how many pips of risk you have the amount of allocation
in terms of the leverage that you're using in the trade that's the most important thing
and that's the most important thing that gets abused most of the time by traders because
every time a trader gets in the marketplace their expectations are how can i make the most
and they don't necessarily think about the other side of that sword because if the edge you're
trying to chop with okay or swing if it makes contact with your target then yes you are
profitable but if it comes back and hits you in the head okay you're burying that axe right in
your skull so that leverage is going to be counterproductive to you it's going to hurt
you at that point it's not going to be beneficial to you it's going to harm you so i'm teaching you
the low threshold entry but i'm also teaching you in addition to that i'm showing you how to build
an additional perspective that helps you find the better entries that allows you to shorten
the number of pips or points if you're trading with the index futures okay but long story short
this would be your range you can work within and it trades up into that secondary fair value gap
now some of you might say well what happens if i put a limit up here well that would be obviously
a stellar entry but you don't necessarily need that okay why i like this one is because if you
look at the 15 minute time frame it was like this that was the range okay so if we go up in that
range to the upper end of it look over here what do we have all three of these candles here
one two three the order block begins with this candle slow it's one two three candles making
one consecutive bearish order block some of you are commenting in a section of the video saying
i thought i understood order blocks now i'm confused because you're hearing people
parrot what i've said in certain circumstances and they don't understand what an order block is
okay this is why i get upset when people try to teach what they heard me teach about one or two
times and the buzzword is what's being tossed around so that way people can sell their courses
and get clicks on their videos you have no idea learning about order blocks from anybody else on
youtube i'm gonna make it very plain and make a blanket statement right there i'm not trying to
hurt anybody's feelings because i know a lot of you out there that try to talk about order blocks
you have a lot of respect for me but i'm trying to correct you because i know you have a large
audience that some of you have a very large audience and you're doing things that are not
accurate okay so i know you're watching my videos so that way you'll correct what you're doing
so that way your viewers won't be harmed or they won't use something that's done incorrectly
and dubbed as my order block and if they have hardship or difficulty doing it it's
not going to be attributed to the concepts being affected because they are effective it's just
they haven't been taught properly okay it's easy to talk about it in hindsight but it's real hard
to do it in real time unless you know what you're doing so the logic is we we ran up into this
daily fair value gap that's what this level is up here this red line was this relative equal highs
on the hourly chart remember that and you're gonna probably need to watch this video a few
times because i've gone through a lot already but i'm breaking down the market and this run here is
the run into that imbalance and above the relative equal highs so this is the bearish order block
it's the consecutive run on this time frame the five minute chart it does not need to get up into
this last up close candle before down close because that's what everybody says an order block is it is
not that notice it doesn't even get up to that does it why because what i'm showing you here
what makes an order block valid it has to have an imbalance without the imbalance
there is no order block that's why it's not supplying demand okay there are specific rules
i'm going to cut through candles supply and demand requires fresh zones okay that's nonsense i have
no affinity for anything like that i'll cut through fractals and go through and find something over
here and still trade on it so that violates the supply and demand theory right there so that's the
distinction and why i laugh at people that say oh he's teaching really nothing new i'm really
teaching you something that no one's talking about unless i talk about it first they're saying what i
said and not to sound egotistical i'm not trying to be egotistical but i i want you to learn it
correctly folks okay i only want to see you do it the right way because if you do it the right way
you will find the results you're looking for if you don't want to do what i'm teaching you're
not going to be consistent you're not going to find longevity and you're going to get frustrated
and you're going to think that this stuff doesn't work because you didn't learn it properly from the
person that created it the order block is all three consecutive candles the reason why this
last up close candle is not even traded to is because the higher time frame parent imbalance
that 15 minute time frame which is being shown here that range of that low and that candles high
here it stops there so there's no necessity for it to trade up into that last candle
so if it trades up into this candle here the bottom one the last one of the three going up
that's enough for me and take that over here and then we have this imbalance so in my mind
this imbalance is sufficient we don't need this one and you wouldn't expect that last
up close candle to be traded too so this is the ideal scenario that i think the mentorship on
youtube should be looking for now as soon as you have this this is one you settle in on what do
you met with another little fair value gap right above it so what were the rules that i gave you
when it has that in the chart think it is going to be a likelihood that it could trade up in there
but your limit order to enter is down in here because it might not get up here what am i trying
to do i'm trying to teach you how to avoid missing trades because a lot of you are going to want to
put an order up in here and yes it would have been filled on this instance but many times you're
going to have an order placed at a really overzealous price point that if you nail it it's beautiful
but they don't happen a lot it's fleeting it happens once in a while so i'm trying to give
you something that it allows you to operate consistently gives you lots of setups that will
allow you to practice also back test like i'm showing you here this is how you back test because
this has already happened but these are all the things that i'm teaching you in this mentorship
and i talked about this level here in my own private group beforehand and you also knew about
the bias being bears on this pair from tuesday's trading or tuesday's episode in this mentorship
on the youtube channel okay so we have a break in this low here so there's an internal shift in
market structure it's bearish we have the imbalance here that's been refined down into
the five minute chart in concert with the bearish order block the lowest down close candle we've
talked about why we're not looking at the last up close candle before the down move so we're
canceling all that misconception and it runs up into the level with the rule i gave you if we
settle in on a fair value gap and it has a small one above it expected it might trade up there so
your risk has to incorporate that so that's the reason why i'm telling you your stop loss could
be here yes it might be a little bit too rich for some of you because you want to trade with
one pip stop loss a half a pip stop loss there's a lot of guys out there trying to do ultra ultra
short-term stuff you might be able to pull it off once in a while maybe you know a series of trades
but i promise you when you start putting down size on these trades
you're not going to pull that off okay it just isn't going to happen so don't get used to trying
to do it okay plus it's easy to do other things you can walk away from the charts and not be chained
to it because if you have a small ultra short stop i don't care how good you are you're going
to sweat it you're going to be expecting you're going to get stopped out what happens if it stops
i'm not worried about getting stopped out i'm not worried about if the market moves
to my stop i'm more interested in the market moving where i think it's going to go
whereas that that's this level down here that's the sixth of april's low okay yeah we went lower
than that already here let me get this thing out of your way if you take this and move out of the
way here we have the an early run at uh five o'clock or so in the morning it made that at 5 25
new york local time in the morning it swept the previous days low so the 6th of april was swept
then we rallied up and we hit the level that what our bias called for in other words i'm looking
for this level to be traded to before i go short so i'm not taking anything in london i'm not
worried about anything in london because london didn't give me the initial rally higher into this
area when does it go up here it's going up there at 9 30 in the morning new york local time
so it hits that level it's at a really rich premium and i know my discount level i'm looking
for for targeting so here's the framework the setup we have our market structure shift
we had disqualified all these upper candles here the lower candle that's where you're going to aim
for what's the order block that you trade for michael what's the one what's the right order block
how do i pick the right order block i just answered it what is an order block it's a
change in the state of delivery the algorithm changes its state of delivery as soon as we get
below this candle's open the market starts delivering sell side and then it breaks this
swing low so now we have changed gears internally any rally after that is just setting up another
run to go lower so in other words this is a suspect rally okay so this is an intermediate term
high swing high because it has the imbalance it should not trade higher than a high that's
the reason why i'm telling you you can put your stop loss there you see how the rules are coming
together i'm not complicating it i'm literally telling you everything i've taught and i'm putting
it into the chart everything was said before it happened and here it is it's the framework it's
the logic and i'm teaching you with great detail that you otherwise would have never learned so
i'm taking you in over top the chart giving you the framework and giving you the logic i'm giving
you the what if this what if that conditions okay i'm telling you how to negate certain order blocks
that you would otherwise expect to see it trade to because of different youtube channels or other
people trying to teach my stuff and they don't know what you're talking about okay they have no
idea what you're doing this setup here gives us a nice opportunity to get short so you could be a
seller here on a limit entry so you place your limit order here and you just walk away from it
you let it go now what happens if it doesn't fill you by 11 30 pull the order it's it don't put it
you know good till cancel just pull it because you want to be entering on the day that it creates
this because relative equal highs if it doesn't drop off it could come up in at a time of day
where you won't really want to be there and it could fill you and then keep on running and take
out the relative equal highs at a deeper pass and stop you out so it's important to know why
the kill zones are there kill zones are when you determine your entry and you place your orders and
you walk away you don't need to have your entry filled inside that kill zone window your order
idea and your order placement needs to be considered at that time if you can't derive
a order placement for setup or a trade entry by that time you have nothing to do and that's it
you've basically taken no risk on and you have to wait till the next trading opportunity or trading day
okay and the market obviously starts to break lower and then
trades to it here at 245 so at 245 it fills it and that's the end of that so not bad it's
10 20 30 40 pips so there you go 40 pips you don't get the very highest high and it ultimately
goes a little bit lower who cares you you've structured a trade that makes sense
and it's just a really nice run up there and everything's delivered on the basis of the logic
and the elements i'm teaching you in this youtube channel and you can't argue with it it's it's
obvious it's so plain to see how these markets are being delivered and if you're one that likes
to argue and say there isn't an algorithm or if you say that these concepts don't work and all
that stuff it's because you want some excuse why you can't do it yourself and i don't want any of
you to feel that way okay i don't get a high or you know get my rocks off because people
stumble and not do well with this because i know why they're not doing well you're not doing the
work that's required that means going through your charts and doing what i just did here every single
day and being passionate about it looking at what it is that has been shown in price action
what is it doing what is it not doing the things i've taught you in this lesson tonight
is in my mind it's charter level teaching it literally is something that i would generally
reserve for charter members only that means the people that have been with me for a year or more
and they're under my tutelage in my private community so this is a lesson that literally
would come from that type of student level but i'm applying it to what you're learning with this
model it's applicable to forex it's applicable to bonds it's applicable to gold it's applicable
but let me put this because i see a lot of people also saying can you show it in gold gold is
one of those markets that is an event-driven market okay and what that means is it usually
requires some kind of geopolitical or something crazy causing it to move otherwise it's highly
manipulated there's a lot of stop hunts and then consolidations it's very frustrating okay it's
it's not a market i believe that someone should be aggressively short-term trading i don't think
that's the ideal market there's plenty other markets out there that you can do that with
and have better consistency and longevity now am i saying there aren't people out there that are
making money consistently in gold no i'm not saying that i'm saying because i'm speaking to
people with the expectation that you're just now learning how to do this i'm aware that there's a
lot of you that are veterans that have been trading longer than the average person coming
to my youtube channel but i have to speak in a language that is palatable for a new viewer
otherwise i'm going to speak to and this might be too lofty for a new viewer anyway but it hopefully
it will intrigue them to see that there's a rhyme and reason to everything i'm teaching and they
repeat it keeps happening every single day these signatures repeat so the question is going to be
is what are you going to do with this information are you going to just say okay well this is great
but this is too much work so i'm going to look for something else that gives me a moving average
crossover or some kind of a bell and whistle to put things on my chart to tell me what to do
and then you're basically creating a religious trading style because you're trusting something
other than price because what have i shown you here just price there's no indicators here i'm
only putting these areas in here with this rectangle to highlight an imbalance i don't
have these on my chart in time you won't either but in the beginning while you're learning it's
important to annotate your chart so that way when you log them in your study journal that way at the
end of the week you go back and look at all the intraday price action then you look at how the
weekly chart worked within that whole panoramic view of intraday daily price action how did it
all fit together and by doing that you're literally getting snapshots of every individual day
then the daily chart and the weekly chart and how it fulfilled its entirely weekly range when was
the high form when was the low formed what was the biggest day of the week what was the framework
around that biggest day of the week of movement and then also break down obviously like we're
showing you here where trade setups it doesn't make a difference if you didn't trade it everything
anybody ever learns is always done by hindsight you want to be a doctor a surgeon guess what
you're doing you're working in hindsight you're studying medical journals that about things that
took place that you were not there okay you're studying hindsight don't let these goobers out
there try to discourage you from studying because i'm teaching you how you are going to get better
at this you do what i just showed you how to do right here and you do it every single day
you're going to develop your own style of keeping notes in your charts i'm not going to do that
here because i don't want to make a an example and feel like you have to do exactly what i said
okay what i mean by that it's to me it's fascinating to see people comment in the
comment section of the videos or they'll send me an email or i'll listen to people that obviously
are trained under me and they make videos on youtube i can hear my fingerprints or read my
fingerprints in the way they talk they'll say certain things certain words certain expressions
i can i can see my own fingerprints on them this part i always leave empty and i do the same way
of teaching even in a private group because i never show them annotations outside of the
things i'm showing because over here you might write an observation about something that you
may want to further investigate that i might not even touch on in this discussion or lecture
but it's important to you so you use the space in your chart to write those things down and then
you come back to that chart on saturday at the end of the week or sunday if that's the day you're
going to do it on and you revisit the entire week and you walk through the entire week of
how it delivered how many pips did it move and how much risk would have been incurred
in the trade so all those things work towards a model that you'll grow accustomed to trusting
because you'll have back data and you'll have examples that you've trained yourself to see
over time and by doing this your psychological makeup as a trader will be formed with these
things in mind so that way when you're watching price action it'll leap off at the chart when
it's forming and you'll remember something you saw hundreds or thousands of times before that
generally repeat over and over and over again does every single day look exactly like this no
but there's a lot of similarity to the things i'm showing you here that repeat so it's it's a matter
of knowing what you're looking for if two bears are walking in the snow
one's younger and one's older and they're walking in the snow will both footprints look exactly the
same no but you'll recognize they're both bear prints and you'll recognize which one's larger
or older and which one's younger so that's what it's like when you're looking at these
signatures in price action they are generally very close to one another in terms of repeating
the same type of way but they're not going to be so identical that they're indistinguishable to
the next one like you'll be able to see that that's a different day of trading
but you'll still recognize these repeating phenomenon that is so telling in the marketplace
but you can't fully appreciate it right now because you're only now just becoming introduced
to it and maybe you've watched some of my videos maybe you watched all my videos and you see when
i do this and it resonates with you you're like man i can i get it because he's shown it to me
but then you go out into the chart and you try to do it and it just feels like your chart doesn't is
organized or it's not so obvious to you what you're looking for that's normal that's how
it was for me for a long time in the 90s for a long time i struggled and floundered of trying
to figure out what i'm supposed to be looking for i'm teaching you the things that repeat your
job is to keep going into the chart annotating them and keeping a running log a study journal
of what the price action has done and what you're observing you can't get hurt because
it's already happened the moves already happened so you're studying it so what you're creating
is the greatest technical analysis book that you're ever going to own and you're doing it
in your own words with your own work because when you buy a book what are you getting you're
getting snapshots of something they're saying this is the important thing about this particular
chapter or the theme of this particular book i'm showing you how you need to stop buying books
there is no books out there except for the ones i put in that one video that's in my library
honestly that's it no other books are necessary in trading in my opinion it's just it's the same
garbage that's repeated and rehashed and people are just trying to do a cash grab
you're not going to learn anything except for bad habits and flawed logic now when you've created
a study journal with thousands of examples and you've been doing it for years you're going to
be astonished of how much of a technical analyst you are years from now and you'll be able to see
a lot more setups that you just don't see like there's several opportunities in this time frame
or this fractal here on a five minute chart there's lots of little trades in here
i'm not going to go through and pick them all out because this is going to create a thousand
different questions and you're going to miss or overlook the very thing i've shown you in this
lecture but this is a model that obviously works in this time frame in this pair it's in 4x it's
not highly specific only to futures notice that it's pretty clear in it it may not have been clear
before i walked through it with you but you learned hopefully a great deal of things tonight
you learned a little bit about order blocks what makes an order block based on the fair value gap
how do you differentiate how you look at the order block how do you break it down how do you
invalidate the certain parts of the order block how do you know it's not going to go in the upper
half of the order block or the last up close candle before it goes down i taught that tonight
so hopefully this has been insightful to you and obviously we'll be back at again next tuesday
until i talk to you then enjoy your weekend and be safe